good afternoon we are now
live good afternoon and welcome to this
new session of the webinar series of the
ftth council Europe I'm Vincent G the
director general of the
council and I I'm very happy to have you
with us uh this afternoon for a very
interesting session titled concering the
rural Broadband challenge
uh the session is sponsored and
organized by U the ftth council member
IQ
J and before I introduce you to to our
speakers today and to the topic maybe
more in detail I will um share some
housekeeping item um maybe John if you
could move to the next
slide yeah we still we still have quite
a few attendees reaching us but I think
these few slides will give us uh will
give them time to to join us so maybe a
few words about the ftth council for
those who are not familiar with the
organization we are a nonprofit
organization founded in 2004 our
objective or mission is to promote full
fiber Network um as a sustainable and
future proof connectivity for Europe um
we organized many events uh the ftth
conference as a physical event and this
series of webinar we also produce a lot
of pieces of information in term of
Technology market research uh all
related to the deployment and Adoption
of full fibo networks in
Europe next slide
please so this um this webinar today uh
is part of a series of webinar we are
organizing approximately once a month um
they give to to Industry expert
possibility to look at the ftth uh
Market from a specific
angle uh and so registering to uh to
this webinar you will also be uh if you
accepted that um receiving further uh
invitation for for the session we're
going to have in the next future next
slide we will record the session uh and
give you access to the full report of
this session uh via an email you will
receive after this session so um the
session is recorded you will have access
to that and we will also share uh the
deck which is used today together uh
with that link to the replay uh via the
thank you email you will receive at the
end of the
session uh you are very much encouraged
to ask question um to do so you need to
use the control panel uh which you must
have uh seen puming up on your on your
desk and there is a question section
where you can type your question we'll
do our very best to to handle most of
the question uh during the the last part
of uh this webinar and if in case we are
not able to cover the question this
question will be uh forwarded to um to
iqo and I'm sure they will um contact
you and and provide you with the answer
uh to to the specific question which
wouldn't have been addressed during the
the Q&A part of this
session so with that I can see that um
we we have more and more attendees
joining us maybe we go to the very last
slide of my part John um and that's the
opportunity for me to to introduce
really the the theme of the question and
our speakers uh we focus on uh
challenges facing uh rural fiber
deployment and what what is very
interesting to see and and that comes
clearly from the studies of the ftth
council Europe is that ftth coverage in
rural area is still lagging behind there
is a gap of 20 points between the
average ftth coverage uh in Europe and
the coverage we measure in very low
density areas which means that it's more
difficult um it requires specific effort
and there are as we will see today some
um operators and and some technology uh
leveraging a specific model and and and
specific approach to make uh deployment
of fiber in rural area very much
possible so I hope you will you will
learn a lot from this session which will
try and explain how to optimize rural
fiber deployment how to streamline
planning and construction workflow how
to build a multi-skilled field team and
how to support remote location with
mobile software uh as well to um go
through this topic uh I'm very pleased
to be joined by um John Talon who is
sales director of iqg and John will
explain more about his company and the
services uh they bring to to the
market and we also have with us Gareth
Carter who is commercial director at
come a um British um operator really
focusing on Ultra rural area in the
northern part uh of Britain so I guess
the floor is yours um I will join you
towards the end of the session to manage
and moderate
Q&A oh that's fantastic thank you uh
Vincent and and so welcome everyone to
Conquering the rural Broadband challenge
um with myself um and with Gareth and um
you know to start with I mean IQ Geo
we're A supplier of specialist GEOS
special software to the telecoms and
utilities Industries um and the software
is only um meant for those who are
building or um construing and operating
networks um so it's not a generic GIS
type product it is a very specific Suite
of software and and you know we are
often asked um we talk to many many
companies um and you might expect and uh
over the last three years or so that
I've been with iqo we've talked to many
of the UK alt Nets as you know um
probably across Europe as well it's a
very growing Community uh we're well
over a 100 maybe 150 alter of network
providers um in the UK now and we've
talked to many of them over the years
and there's a set of recurring themes
and challenges that come up whether it's
rural or whether it's Urban often they
are the same same but there's obviously
some very specific things that relate to
um rural builds which we'll cover today
um which are um uh doubly difficult um
types of
challenges um and one of the things that
we're constantly asked the first thing
we're usually asked is um is there a
single digital environment that we can
operate within is there some software um
that we can use that covers our whole
life cycle from start to finish and and
that's one of the things that iqg
specialize in and and just to talk
through that a little bit um starting
with the planning and design side when
we often talk to companies especially
when they're starting out they want to
make sure that they've got um a
supporting technology platform for
things like the planning and design
aspects that will scale with them as
they grow um and they often have a
profile of starting small but then
gaining investment and then ramping up
really quite quickly um and so therefore
what we've done at iqg is we have all
the tools and the software to start with
a manual type of planning and design but
we also um have built into the software
the automated planning from comsoft So
within the same single environment uh
you can start small and then grow and
accelerate your um uh designs and have
all the other supporting Technologies um
as you grow and scale as a company um
one of the things that's very important
here in the UK and I know there similar
initiatives across Europe um is what we
call physical infrastructure access from
open reach so this is access to the duct
and pole information um that you get
from from British Telecom or open reach
in order to try and accelerate um the
build programs it's opened up to the
alnet communities and across Europe I
know there's the ATI or access to
infrastructure initiatives that probably
does something very similar um one of
the things that almost every company
that we talk to wants to do is they want
to be able to interact digitally with
the apis that open reach have um set up
and so we have a a p module as we call
it within our software that allows you
to access the records from open reach
and download into
iqg um the duct and pole information you
might want to
use and that's usually the first step at
which the operators decide to take the
information out into the field um
because they want to verify that the the
duct and pole information they see is
suitable for their build and they also
want to make sure that they understand
if any work needs to be undertaken
sometimes the Ducks get silted up for
example uh and they need to be able to
advise open reach to do some work um so
what we've done is create that module to
be able to take that data out into the
field and do some field verification
once you've done that uh typically you
would bring that information back um and
then use that in your designs uh and
refine your designs perhaps into a lower
level design to be able to go on and
support the construction process and
once again at this point typically the
information is created as job packs and
given out to either contractor companies
or your own work Crews um but also um
one of the things that many companies
want to do is they want to do away with
the paper stage of that and do
everything digitally and so once again
within the same environment all the
information on your detail designs can
be given out uh into the field on
tablets or or phones but typically
tablets for the detail um and then be
able to interact with the software in a
way that allows you to um provide
evidence of what's been built so perhaps
photographs for example um Andor mark up
the designs in case has been any last
minute changes and what that means is
that again in this digital workflow you
get back the as built um outcome
directly back into your core iqj
inventory uh to allow you to go on and
and operate and maintain that netword
but also to release the premises to your
sales organization uh to be able to um
you know um reduce the time to
revenue uh and so I mentioned piie and
um there's also quite a lot more to this
open reach Pia apart from just
downloading the data and viewing it um
and they've added a number of apis
digital apis um to their portfolio this
is open reach um and we have now added
to our portfolio as well um things such
as notices of intent or nois as they're
known here in the UK which is the the
the the process which um Network
providers have to to go through in order
to advise open reach of what
infrastructure that they actually want
to use kind of reserve it in a way um
and that's the whole process um and
we're also now going on to add um
there's a particular um form if you have
a duct blockage for example or you need
to advise open reach some work that
might need to be done there's a thing
called an a55 form um which we're now
implementing as well and so over the
next six months or so there's another
whole whole set of items that are coming
into a Pia module um which will help the
UK alnet Community um run a far more
automated process and a digital process
with things like open reach um and as I
mentioned um excuse me one of the one of
the important things is to empower field
Crews and take that Network to the field
and of course that's something that
we've touched on in the workflow and
you'll hear a lot more about that when
when Gareth explains what alom do um but
it's a bit more than that because
because everyone whether you're in the
office or on the field and if you're
connected it gives you a set of
situation awareness so you can actually
see what's going on so for example you
can see the progress of build at any
point in time which is very useful ac
across the whole
organization and we find that in today's
modern world um especially the younger
generation and I can say that um are
coming in with expectations of how
applications work um they really have
that sort of commercial view of how how
easy application should be to work with
and we've spent a lot of time IU trying
to ensure that that's exactly how our
software operates and that the it's very
familiar when they see it um it embeds
things like Google Maps and street view
and so on and so it's a very familiar
environment for people coming into to to
use the commercial software and ideally
the whole thing is to be able to do
everything completely digitally to
saying get it right get it right first
time so um throughout our uh webinar
today we have um a couple of poll
questions for the audience um just to
give us an idea for those of you who are
building networks out there whether
you're operating mostly in urban areas
in rural or perhaps a mix of both
perhaps if I can ask the poll to run
yeah John I think the the poll is now
open I would definitely encourage you to
to answer the question directly and
maybe to to rephrase uh where are you
deploying fiber networks urban areas
rural area or a mix of both um let let's
maybe give a a couple of
um seconds more for for the audience to
to raise their view uh and John what
would what would be your um your
guess let me put put you a little bit on
the spot
I I my guess would be that because of
the billing of the um the rural nature
of the webinar that I'm hoping we'll see
a very large contingent of rural um
interest okay okay so it's hope more
than prediction uh yes I think
so okay well I think uh I'm not sure
everybody has uh responded I think I see
55% of the attendance but maybe not
everyone is in the position of answer so
I will close the poll because I think
the the results are getting uh now more
or less
stable um and I
will share the
results and
actually predictions were not that
correct John uh six 60% have a mix of
both urban and rural area um mostly
rural nevertheless is uh 26% and 177%
being mostly Urban so I don't know if
you want to comment on that yeah yeah
thank you very much vce I mean it it's
not surprising um the reason for that I
guess I guess is that many of the
companies that we talk to um are not
solely rural yeah that they often
operate in purly served areas which can
be um relatively Urban as well in terms
of towns and so on but they also then
expand to the countryside um from those
areas so actually um that's a very good
result excellent so I think uh I close
the the result and you can uh carry on
with the with the next slides on on your
deck great thank you so much um so um a
few words for me about our customer our
customer oncom um oncom have been with
us now for just under three years um and
as it says on their their website it's a
snapshot from their website here um they
are the rural Broadband experts um which
is fantastic and they
specialize in bringing Broadband to
locations as it says there that other
Telecom providers uh fail to um fail to
get to um and so they have a wonderful
outlook on life um up in the northeast
of England and they team up with a lot
of the communities there in the
community organizations so in particular
this one from i north umberland um where
as you can see the comment is that
they're always Keen to find solutions
for these rural communities and are
always professional enthusiastic and
Keen to help residents and businesses
and I think that will come across when
you hear um from Gareth because they're
really embedded at the heart of their um
quite wonderful area um and for those of
you that don't know the the geography
necessarily of the northeast of England
very well um they're based in anik which
is right up there on the Northeast Coast
um north of Newcastle upon time and just
south of the Scottish borders they um
are alongside a very beautiful stretch
of Coast the previous slide there had
the the beautiful Bamber Castle um on it
but also right on the edge of the two
national well a national park nor
umberland National Park and the ker
Forest Park so an extremely uh beautiful
area um and you know a few words for me
before I hand over to Gareth I guess um
you know one of the things that that we
saw in alcom uh was that they really did
recognize that digital divide that you
commented on Vincent at the start of the
presentation between the urban and rural
areas and as I said they have a very
beautiful but a challenging area um with
some really difficult to reach
communities and businesses and they have
a lot of um tourism and there's a lot of
holiday communities and so on out there
and of course there's an expectation
there's you and I going to a holiday
house for example um that you will have
an internet connection when you get
there um and much of that relies on on
alol in this area um because many of the
parts of the region are very poorly
served um but uh alcom Rose to the
challenge with wireless and now full
fiber
connectivity um and as part of that they
needed of course some and this was part
of our early conversations they needed
the right supporting
technology to be able to uh operate very
effectively and efficiently um from
design and construction all the way
through to operation and they have a
great philosophy and it says on their
website again uh that they like to get
it done and leave no one behind which is
fantastic I hope that applies to the
work crews in the field as well um and
they also have um again a wonderful turn
of phrase on the website it used to say
run a website from a wood live stream
from a stream or play Minecraft from a
mountain it's all possible with uh
Broadband from
hcom so without um you know uh promoting
you too much Gareth um I'm going to pass
over to you now uh and um let the
audience now hear from the rural
Broadband expert thank you John good
afternoon
everyone so alen com um we were founded
in
1983 uh I joined the company 15 years
ago uh when we were just a computer game
shop uh just a two of us um stepen pinch
and the MD and myself uh we started to
do it support for businesses in rural
Northland um who demanded better
connectivity for online services and we
expanded to become a rural wisp uh
utilizing the government's rural voucher
scheme serving over a thousand customers
in 2020 uh this evolved into an fdtp
Network um and we started rolling out
fiber from there
one of um the biggest land owners in
Northland Northland Estates uh they
recognize the contribution we were
making to the rural economy and wanted
to be part of alanc so became one of our
investors along with Lord James
Percy uh all our staff uh they all local
uh come from VAR backgrounds we've got
plumbers uh chefs electricians we've got
a variety of uh variety of Staff um but
Alan our main focus uh we're very
Community focused company um we get
heavily involved with local communities
when building our networks um we want
communities to ask us to build to
them next slide please John yeah thanks
G I think that's absolutely key I mean
you know be being close to the community
and and it's great to see that um you've
got such a range of people um from chefs
to electricians and whatnot so so I
guess your own your own maintenance in
cas in pretty well
covered yeah staff barbecues work very
well oh
yes so Al Alan con we currently cover
from the borders of England in Scotland
and down to current uh County Durham uh
which cover some of the most rural
locations in the
UK next slide please
[Music]
Jo so before we used iqg uh all our
Network planning was done on paper and
Google Earth uh using the open reach
portal to work out assets from the Pia
network uh basically what we can do to
uh for the build um our very first
Network build was actually designed and
built on the Fly um this worked
relatively well when we building small
networks um but it became very
complicated uh when doing multiple
builds uh by using IQ Geo uh this has
allowed us to actually uh monitor the
build program
uh from our office uh it's a live system
so all our changes are updated in real
time job packs are now created from iqo
which means no more paper um and we can
easily generate reports so the fivr Bild
is fully
auditable because um obviously being in
rural Northland um the the Bro mobile
broadband signal is uh very poor all our
job packs are downloaded and available
offline on iPads for
engineers and then there's synced at the
end of the day updating updating all
progress and
modifications
next so couple of well one question if I
may around that then so you know I've
highlighted and and You' mentioned there
about the the mobility aspects of the
software and you said about taking into
the field um you know so what what does
that what does that do for for your
Crews and and what does it do for you in
the field then does it you know give you
that ability to not worry about you know
the everything thing you're doing is
being
recorded yeah so before we actually um
before we started using iPads in the
field um obiously it was all paper uh
and in rural uh Northland in the winter
it's it's not great and uh we found lots
of bits of missing paper so it wasn't a
full picture of um the network design uh
for our Engineers so that was one of the
reasons why we switched to the iPads uh
it's all saved on the iPads and the guys
can work from the iPads and make changes
as they go if I guess in what i' call
the olden days then when we were using
paper um they um you know just just
having to bring that back soggy wet or
otherwise and then being able to try and
update records just wasn't really um an
efficient way of working not at all um
because obviously when it's a miserable
weather outside trying to update a piece
of paper with a you know pen and ruler
and what have you
it doesn't come back as as it should do
so it was uh yeah it was quite hard
really to to do that but the iPads have
bit of a game changer to be fair great
thank
you so this is uh this is essentially
how we used to do um Network build it
was all on spreadsheets uh all our
splice diagrams all done through Excel
uh and pieces of paper and slide there
Sean then this is how we uh this is how
it's all done now so all splice diagrams
are recorded through IQ Geo and the
these are all visible um on our
Engineers iPad so um spice Engineers can
just work work through them uh as they
go and it's all saved and any changes
required can be changed and updated at
the
office excellent sorry John okay
um so alanc what makes us different over
isps Al alanc are an inative
uh inative in our Network design
architecture apologies we only use the
best equipment um testing everything
before we implement it and we adapt
existing technology um what Alan con
done a short while ago uh we
strengthened our senior operations team
um and so Al encom now we have our own
build um training facility so we recruit
all local people from many different
backgrounds but we're able to retrain
them in house uh create creating a
highly effective homegrown labor
workforce building networks to the
highest standards um we promote from
within and optimize our talent guarantee
the core values of Alan alom not
lost sorry go on Gareth I was going to
ask you a question but I'll do it at the
end um We Believe by empowering
individuals you get employees that will
go the extra mile um as a fiber build in
rural North fumbling it's not always fun
uh this became very very real when uh
after storm orn um when um all our
employees volunteered to come in on a
Sunday to get our customers back online
um after storm or storm was one of the
biggest storms the UK have had for a
while um so after storm RN uh our
networks were down to 11% operational
after the storm on a Sunday morning we
had them back up to 80% by Sunday
afternoon 90% in less than a week after
the storm leaving only those relying on
open reach polls um still
offline um we then bypassed uh the open
reach PS polls to get everyone back uh a
week later um just as well really
because uh the open PS actually were
down for several months um so you know
after a week we managed to get all our
customers back online um and that that
was by putting new polls in um and and
by well yeah bypassing the existing
polls um because of our multikill staff
I and and IQ Geo uh we were able to
pinpoint the issues before leaving the
office and had a solution placed very
quickly um one of our suppliers adran uh
they visited us um recently couldn't
believe how forward pushed the known
limits of their equipment um and because
of our history uh alanc have actually
built very close relationships with many
uh land owners in north fand and Durham
uh which makes getting we leaves a
simple and quick process for
ourselves um as we've already got Master
we leaves in
place
I think that was one of the one of the
things that and having met some of your
team as well um Gareth um you know this
thing about staff being multi-skilled is
one of the areas that does make you
quite unique I wonder if you could
elaborate a little bit on and you
mentioned just at a training academy as
well which is great but whole multi
skill nature um of things I wonder if
you could elaborate on that a little bit
because I think that does make quite a
difference yeah so all our staff we tend
to get um a lot lot of uh a lot of our
staff are very young I guess um so
they've been in certain trades um and
yeah when the when they've sort of
applied to join us we we look for we
look for guys that will um you know go
the extra mile are very keen and
enthusiastic because they're the guys
who are going to um you know P pull it
out the park really when required when
you're up against it um when the
weather's really bad and you've got an
issue or you know you've got got a time
limit on a build and um they Haven to
work late into the night they're the
guys who are going to completed for
you yeah and I guess the thing about
being multi-skilled is the fact that you
can you know get it done once when when
when you send them out you know you can
rely on them to be able to do each
other's roles as necessary and be able
to just get it done in the most
efficient and effective way I guess yeah
exactly so our um our Engineers
obviously if if we can uh when basically
send one engineer out and he can do
multiple tasks um it doesn't need any
revisits it doesn't need um you know
extra extra Engineers or anything like
that one one guy's skilled to to do
multiple tasks and uh you know complete
the complete a
job that's that's
fantastic yeah
guys yeah that's life and and I have to
say I I do like the range of wonderful
vehicles equipment that you have this
one looks quite
fun yeah so so we've got lots of uh
obviously being where we are uh the
weather can uh deteriorate pretty
quickly in North umland uh especially
over the winter so we've got a variety
of vehicles to it's mainly for servicing
on network um because in the winter it
gets quite you know hairy and um we've
got lots of different 4x4s that can get
us where we need to get to uh without
getting stuck
so yeah
yeah so basically what the rural fiber
build um in Northland uh so the majority
of alencon fiber builds uh we they
actually started off as a wireless
network um but by utilizing Wireless
technology uh we're able to connect
customers fast but then follow it up
with uh with the fiber build um this
allows us basically because not a huge
amount of planning uh required uh with
obviously building a wireless network if
a customer comes to us and wants uh uh
wants a connection and obviously we can
justify it um from a cost angle then we
can connect them straight away onto our
wireless
network um and then you know plan and um
get the right where leaves and what have
you place it just gives us that little
bit of time to um to to build a network
to a high standard um which obviously
one benefits uh at the end of the day um
one of our recent bills actually uh was
to build a full fiber Network covering
over 30 kilometers of uh remote
Countryside uh covering over 18 Villages
and hamlets um but by employing every me
method possible uh to deliver a fiber
infrastructure uh we cross rivers fields
fges mland and by installing new
Telegraph poles plow and armored cable
um all VI our remote control track plows
um ducked in along the Verge using blown
fiber uh the project was all managed by
uh obviously state-ofthe-art offline
mobile software that helps us to deploy
capture and uh maintain the fiber
Network um alencon we we only use the
best um software te technology equipment
fiber materials such as IQ Geo prisum
adran and Corning um so on completion of
uh this this rural fiber build uh would
made a total of 669 ready for service
premises and as as of March 2023 we've
had a 37% take up um on that rural
build um so part of that we actually um
we overcame um many extreme rural
challenges um installing infrastructure
over uh over 30 km of back hall cable uh
cross the remote northon
Countryside um this included um narrow
60 M hour roads
Rivers uh historical Bridges places of
significant
interest um amongst many more challenges
uh but by uh Le Ling with the national
parks uh forestry commission local
Council land
owners uh we were actually able to
navigate through the difficult and
challenging terrain and uh successfully
provision Ultra fast fiber across a vast
area not missing anyone along the
way uh one of the properties we actually
connected uh was linup Lodge which is
owned by Lord James Percy and one of the
best shooting lodges in the UK uh is one
of the final cluster of properties that
we converted to fiber uh linup lodged so
actually 10 kilomet from our source and
is found in one of the most rural
locations in North umland
well that's that's that's quite amazing
and uh I guess I mean I I I love the
photography um I'm always looking at
your websites and your blog posts on
LinkedIn because you have some great um
imagery of the the area and the builds
that you're doing and I'm also very
intrigued by the uh the remote control
tractors that you use I noticed this one
here uh you know going through a heavily
wooded area that must be really quite
difficult with tree roots and and all
that kind of activity that must be
really quite hard so I guess I'm kind of
wondering are there any sort of special
considerations Network considerations
that um that that you have when you when
you're doing this kind of work and I'm
thinking here about you mentioned about
access and we can see the trees there
and everything but I'm thinking here
about the you know the robustness of the
networking in particular I mean how how
do you get things like power in very
remote
areas so um a lot lot of our power um we
use uh Village Hall
um because we're a community Hub um
basically what we do we put uh we put
fiber into the Village Hall um and then
we use the Village Hall as our uh Source
cabinet um and and sort of bring it out
to the community from there um but by
doing this basically all our uh all our
hubs um you know we've got battery
backup systems fit to every cabinet
um and they've also got gas power
generators um to to back them
up gas rather than
diesel yeah so yeah so gas um whereas
Diesel have a sort of a six Monon shelf
life um gas can actually stay in a
generator um until until needed so
normally you won't need to use a
generator until there's power cuts which
is normally in the winter so you're
talking 12 month periods
um whereas diesel would go off um in in
that time
period ah s practical thinking and also
I think you did mention at one point
that there's a program of of them
becoming solar as well so even Greener
yeah so um North umland uh in North
umland they're actually starting to uh
roll out um putting solar panels on
Village Halls uh with battery backup so
essentially our uh essentially our hubs
are going to be sort of a mini power
plant within communities so we really
shouldn't have problems with
power
so but I mean that's a fantastic example
of how it ties together all the aspects
of the work that you do I think that
that's absolutely tremendous so
um so shall we move on to the next slide
yeah so um we have another poll um so um
I guess Vincent do you want to introduce
this one yeah absolutely uh I will uh
launch the poll and maybe take that
opportunity to also remind our audience
that we accept and welcome questions uh
that you can pose using the the question
box I can see that you have read and
understood how the the poll works so no
need for further
explanation um how important is offline
Mobil to your field crew and I can see
already many of you voting and it goes
from not important to extremely
important so same question
steeve okay what would be the percentage
of extremely important you
guess um from my I would say I would say
extremely important um it's one of those
things that it can be quite um depending
on the the life cycle stage that you're
at in in the growth of a company um
often they start with you know making do
uh but as you scale and grow as we said
earlier um it it becomes an essential
activity and it's also very surprising
how um how many not spots there are in
urban areas as well so um being able to
work with that offline capability I say
would be would be very
important
okay let me see um I think we we had
more than half of the um the audience
having voted and it seems to to be now
um stabilizing so I will um close the
poll and share the results uh you're not
too far off uh John this time uh 32%
think this is extremely important 39%
think this is important uh leaving us
with 25% mutual and and hardly uh just a
handful of respondent thinking this is
not really important so yeah clearly
offline Mobility is uh is very
important fantastic thank you for that
that's great all right let me uh hi then
give you the floor back and once again
uh please ask question so we can address
them in in a few
minutes sure absolutely so well I I mean
thank you to Gareth for such a wonderful
um resume of some of the great work they
do up in Northumberland and some of the
the challenging conditions and the
things that they face there it's very
enlighting to hear um there must be a
tremendous amount of work that goes into
doing things like the liais on with the
not just the communities but the you
know the land owners as we said for we
leaves and so on so whole lot of
activity that's often unsung um but um
obviously results in in very high
equality internet connections for the
community and for the remote businesses
um and I'm very pleased to hear of
course that you know IQ are a key part
of that Journey uh and that we're able
to um provide them with the kind of
Technologies kind of supporting
Technologies across their whole uh their
whole business that that really helps
and we asked the question there about
field mobility and we think it's one of
the things we do rather well we spent a
lot of time in effort uh trying to make
sure that our customers can just get on
with a job they don't need to worry
about it if it's disconnected and and
and you're out in the wild um either
that or in not spots in urban areas that
it really doesn't matter at the end of
the day uh you know you have that
ability to to work and just get on with
the job fundamentally so um so we're
very pleased and very proud of um you
know our customers and and the sort of
work that alcom alcom does so um just in
in wrapping up and I guess um obviously
I'd like to say thank you to the entire
audience for your um attention this
afternoon um it I hope you found it very
interesting and um you know we are I'm
very happy Gareth and I to perhaps ask
any answer sorry any questions that that
you may
have well John and maybe that
one question from Alonso asking in a
very specific way if fiber test
results that that oncom is is is doing
are stored inside the uh the iqg
system yeah so yeah we store we we
started to store all our um all our
tests um it allows the full you know
audable Trace from Engineers who
completed the test to to the actual test
results so that's all stored in
IQ okay yeah and that's just may to
elaborate on that if I may a little bit
I mean things like documents and so on
are are a key part of the sort of
information that can be stored in the
product uh but more than that um also
things like photographic evidence um and
it might be that you do inspection so it
might be that there's some recording of
things like damage and other things like
that um so there's a whole range of
documents photographs and other elements
that can be stored within the system as
well so
yeah okay and maybe a related question
which is you know a little bit technical
um related to your system uh can we
export all design
items um and consider as part of an
inventory
database um yes um we have a range of
standard um formats that we use um to
exchange data we also have a a
particular um structured data format uh
that we can use so yes that's definitely
something that can be done um to to be
able to get data um in and out of the
system um I guess the majority of our
customers um they they will often bring
data in uh sometimes from the design
aspects uh but usually they'll do a lot
of the design work within the software
and then run with it once they once they
get either data in or have designs in
the software um they'll run with it all
the way through the entire life cycle
within that one environment because
that's one of the things that that we're
looking for from a software product okay
I have I mean thanks we're receiving
tons of question I have difficulty to
keep keep up with everything coming on
on the box but I have two question which
are maybe for Gareth related to the
specificity of
deployment condition one was related to
the percentage of your um insulation
which are aial maybe versus uh entr
trenches uh what what what do you use do
you bury the cable on the ground or so
so all the all the all our fibers um
buried in the ground um to be fair we're
very look fortunate that we've got um
very good long relation relationships
with all the land owners in Northland um
it allows us great land access um and
and and part of this we use a lot very
very a lot of
cable okay excellent um yeah I mean
sorry just again to add to that find me
I think that's quite important in in the
design aspects of the network because as
we heard from Gareth when there was a
storm and and you know that would
obviously affect and we're seeing more
natural um you know occurrences of
things like storms and flooding and so
on and many of those things obviously
will affect overhead infrastructure um
not solely of course um again flooding
would affect um but but you've got you
know those kind of increasing
environmental effects now um and so the
ability to um have options I think is
quite
important I have an interesting more
maybe buer related question but that is
that can be directly connected you know
to to uh the techniques use for
deployment which is um you know from
which cost per premise do you consider
that you don't have a business case and
and that it cannot fly and and that
maybe it stop being interesting and
maybe an Associated question about uh
maybe uh Government funding which could
complement potentially uh purely
commercially driven um investment so how
do you maybe you know red cost as much
as you can but where the threshold where
where you need financial support to make
the the business case fly so so I'm
building and and designing a a fiber um
build um we look at a couple of things
really so one's obviously the funding
now we do use uh government vouchers
which does help in the build um but the
thing with rural bills um once you um
build to a hamlet um and you know you've
got customers on your network
chances are it's cost you a lot of money
to build to that Network chances are
another ISP isn't going to be building
to that Network add to that Hamlet
because it's such a hard build so the
customer will be with you for a long
long time as long as you know you offer
them good prices um there's a very SL
chance that they're actually going to
leave you and a lot of our customers you
know they being stayed with stay with us
for a long time even when another fiber
company comes in
like just of basis you know they've got
a good service um yeah no one else is
going to do
it and I guess that I mean that that you
you what you're saying there G is that
you know you're sticky your customers
are sticky um and I guess uh you know
that's a great thing because it it does
uh affect things like property prices
you know I know if you're looking at
purchasing a property you look at the
main utilities and and and you know an
internet connection is a key part of it
so um you know that's very very
important I guess you must have a very
high tech up for for every uh every area
area you cover with your with your
fiber
yeah yeah we we looking at over over 30%
normally for for Ral build at
least okay maybe back to to a more
technical question I have a um someone
Scott asking um is the infrastructure
you lay in the ground to the same
specification as BT or can you deploy a
suitable alternative um for example
fiber manhole or
chamber yeah so all everything we
install um is to open reach standards
are higher um normally higher to be fair
alanc have very high standards ourselves
we only want to build the best networks
so yeah it's open reach standards are
high
and I guess the quality of the network
and the standards that you you adhere to
gur are you know again it may cost
slightly more in the short term but
you've got that um you know income
stream over a longer term but also
you've got um a more robust Network in
the sense that you should hopefully have
less maintenance issues if I'm if I'm
right yeah exactly um you know we we
tend not to have to really go out and do
too many repairs on our Networks because
they very
robust still question from the audience
uh John you prepared for me question in
case I wouldn't get any any question
coming from from the guy on the call but
I I won't use them today uh that one is
is is about uh the advantage of using
remote control
tractors
yes I'm looking forward to this one as
well because I'm fascinated by
them so yeah a lot of rural North
umlands very hilly um obviously can be
quite dangerous if you're um rolling out
fiber uh you know with any other
Machinery so remote control you can keep
a good distance from the actual machine
itself fenan rolles or you know you can
be well clear of it and uh you know our
Engineers can stay
safe and I guess Gareth it must be
really quite powerful again going back
to the slide when you had the you know
the of the the trees and imagine lots of
roots I guess I mean what sort of depth
do they dig to and and you know I guess
they're pretty strong yeah so our um our
plows um do a depth of 600 mil um yeah
so that's what we kind of um yeah it
goes to 600 mil everywhere we plow
though a lot of the land owners um it's
rural um sort of set aside land so it's
never going to be plowed over it's never
going to have crops on so we're very
fortunate that you know once cables in
the ground it's not not going to be
disturbed by anyone or
anything and gar uh another question uh
you've mentioned the quality of your
relationship with land owners which
obviously I think is a critical element
uh driver of your success so I have a
question related to how do you cultivate
this relationship besides you know
sharing the same local pub um what
what's the the key factor which which
drives the quality of your relation with
land land a lot of our relationships
started because we were um an IT support
provider uh originally so so we Alan's
been in the uh Community uh in in in the
county since 1983 so all of our
relationships of land owners have been
built up over a long long time um you
know we're at the point now where can
just you know pick up the phone and um
pop over have a coffee with them and and
iron stuff out you know there's no need
for paperwork passing back and forward
we can go and sit down and just you know
talk it through yeah so that that that's
something which is very much link to
your to to the to the founder uh
background it's not something you can uh
replicate everywhere if you if you start
a new business and try and do that in
another part of the country yeah and for
fortunately yeah I guess it would be
quite hard to do it from scratch um
because it has taken a long time to get
to this point um but yeah are they you
know are they more
transactional um reason besides the
quality of your historical relation
which you could uh uh point I mean for
for for our
audience yeah so we always the the the
key Point obviously uh when when working
out a way leave uh um what we normally
do especially in more fumbling uh land
owners tend to have you know properties
spread out over you know a vast area
what we tend to do is connect those
properties um and and and not charge a
you know charge a very small rental for
them uh a lot less than we would
normally charge uh on a normal customer
and as part of that that just forms the
we Le um you know the land owner gets a
big benefit because they're getting fast
internet to to their rural property
um and we get a benefit that we get to
use the
land okay that's quite it's quite
intriguing yeah I think we have a yeah
we still have a little bit of time um is
Pia imperative for Rural builds John or
or
Gareth um Gare I'll let you answer that
one I don't think so where where we are
in rural Northland uh it's it's not a
necessity we use it because because it's
it's there um and it it makes a build a
lot quicker so if we're installing our
own infrastructure obviously there's
quite a time to it h it takes a lot
longer to do um but by using Pia uh it
does Quicken a build a buildup but if it
wasn't there it probably wouldn't be a
huge miss it would just had a little bit
time to the
build I guess Gareth I'm guessing about
here but um a lot of the Pia is more
pole than duct um information because of
the terrain yeah so in Northland yeah a
lot of it is Paul um and this is we sort
of changed our um mentality I guess
after storn uh because a lot of the PO
did come down and it took um up reach
about several months to to put them back
in so we had to think quick on our feet
to sort of um to get around all
that yeah the C customer service having
customers off for several months
wouldn't be wouldn't be a thing yeah you
wouldn't have
customers
indeed maybe last two three question and
I'm reading I hope I understand the
point what is the input data and what
will be the forecast in the future
demand sorry
sorry so so I'm reading the question I'm
not sure to fully understand uh what
what is behind maybe you you get it
better than I do maybe it's how you do
your designs in the first place Gareth
you're not you're not bringing in
information from other sources you're
doing it in the product is that right
yeah so we've we've got um yeah all
planning team to be fair they they're
very efficient at what they do um and
and we've started obviously when we used
iqg really we've built the design team
the planning team around iqg essentially
and um so they're all very efficient at
what they do uh so what we tend to do we
tend to do a you know a full survey of
where we're going to build and then
that's uh then put into IQ GE and from
there rolled out to Engineers when we
start
building and interesting question I hear
especially for for the ftth council
Viewpoint um I understand you started
leveraging Wireless technology and
you're now running out fiber fix line um
why did you transition from one
technology to another one what what
advantages do you see in in in fixed
line because of course in term of
infrastructure it's much much heavier in
investment uh so what has been your your
journey towards full fiber U from
Wireless Solutions or do you still have
wireless Solutions we we still have some
Wireless Solutions um so so obviously
alanc have been on quite a journey um
you know we started as a computer game
shop and um then when we started doing
it support uh a lot of our customers you
know they were you know high high net
worth land owners in North umland who
had a requirement for fast Broadband um
from there we obviously got into the
wireless and then that kind of just sort
of um we figured well we're doing the
wireless um why don't we connect a
hamlet or a village and the best way to
do that is with uh obiously fiber
because not Everyone likes uh you know a
dish on the side the house especially in
a a rural location Hamlet or whatever
especially if the peper all over the
place okay very good um do you and
that's that one is for Gare specifically
do you follow the Dig ons rule in the UK
or different ISP trench their own cable
path I think you kind of touched on on
it uh earlier but could you specifically
address that question so so do we do we
follow the Dig W's rule in the
UK or um or are they I would say
overbuilding uh activity uh in in your
region from several operators I guess
this is how I understand the question
yeah to to be fair there is several
operators in Northland
um a lot of operators in Northland tend
to stick to the um towns the big towns
and no one really touches the really
rural stuff because it's it's very hard
and if you're given an opportunity to
take an easy easy route or a hard route
the you know majority of people take the
easy route Alan com are slightly
different we take the hard route um you
know because we're aware that you know
we live in a community ourselves we live
in the community where we build in and
we want to give everyone fast
internet okay maybe last quick question
that one is more related to
iqg um support not with the product
itself not with a solution itself with
the training which goes with it to what
extent uh was uh was there a lot of
training requested or or how does the
relation Works in term of
training yeah I mean we we we obviously
did provide some training and so on and
and the product is is actually also well
documented and quite intuitive but
Gareth tell us about your experience of
that yeah so at the start um we got um
yeah we got training off IQ Jo um a lot
of the stuff it's weird because you kind
of as you're designing and planning you
realize ah it would be good if we could
do this it would be good if we could do
that and you know we've kind of worked
with I iqg to to to yeah improve our the
platform we use um to make it work for
us um but yeah we training was you know
and is available um and the
documentation which is provided uh yeah
very easy to follow I
guess okay and I think that that's a key
thing for us as well because customer
success so working with our customers on
the journey that they're on is a very
important thing for
us all right I think we're reaching the
top of the hour I've got a very last
question Gareth uh do you still have
time for computer gaming
not all the the funny thing is I've
never been into computer games at all
uh
yeah well um at least we we'll leave it
on that note uh there are a few question
we've not been able to to address so
I'll forward them to to John and Gareth
and I'm sure they will come back to you
um with with answers if they have not
been already answered by um um or
question moderator is active in the
background so I will I will just thank
everyone for for your your participation
your attendance your your numerous
questions I hope you found this session
insightful uh and I hope to see you on
our next webinar Ser session uh in in a
few weeks thank you very much for for
your attention thanks to John and Gareth
for their wonderful uh presentations
thank you thank thank you everyone thank
you Vincent take
care